[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazing
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano Mi nombre es amal
don offman Y estos son los titulares
persistencia de los atentados yaristas
retirada de los militares franceses y
despliegue de otros actores
internacionales en esta emisión
analizamos que avances políticos y de
seguridad esperan a la región africana
del
Sudáfrica se enfrenta a una crisis
energética sin precedentes y el
presidente Siri la rama fosa ha
declarado el estado de catástrofe
Nacional los detalles en un momento la
ciudad marroquí de marraque es organizó
la primera edición de su festival del
libro africano una oportunidad para que
los escritores africanos se reúnan con
su público y debatan sobre los retos del
continente nuestra corresponsal estuvo
en el evento
abrimos esta edición en el sahell la
región sigue siendo escenario no solo de
mortíferos atentados terroristas sino
también detenciones diplomáticas entre
varias potencias con La retirada de la
presencia militar francesa y el
despliegue de nuevos actores
internacionales como Rusia la crisis de
seguridad en este territorio tan extenso
como Europa y que abarca cinco países se
remonta a 2012 cuando estalló un
levantamiento independentista por parte
de los pueblos tuárez en Mali poco a
poco los grupos yihadistas se unieron a
la rebelión haciéndose gradualmente con
el control de amplias zonas de varios
países de la región la presencia militar
francesa pero también la de la misión de
la ONU en Mali la minusma no han logrado
contener el fenómeno de la violencia
yadista y actualmente hay dos entidades
principales activas alkaida y sus
diversas filiales y el estado y sus
afiliados
para analizar la situación de seguridad
en la región del sahell recibimos a
niágale bagayoko politóloga y
especialista en cuestiones de seguridad
en África occidental
niágale Buen día con el contexto que
acabamos de presentar Cuáles cree que
son los posibles escenarios para la
región del
hay varios elementos
el primero es que cabe esperar que se
produzca un mayor deterioro de la
situación de seguridad de la región del
sagel
por la expansión de los grupos
yihadistas
no solo en Mali sino también en burkina
faso
y cada vez más en el norte de los países
costeros
eso es el primer elemento con tal vez
una esperanza de cierta estabilización
en níger
anoto el limón fundamentado
otro elemento fundamental es que
podríamos asistir a un nuevo estallido
del conflicto de carácter
intercomunitario e independentista en el
norte de Mali con el grandes contento
que está creciendo entre los grupos
firmantes del acuerdo de paz
grupos mayoritariamente tú haré y árabes
que además están enfrentados al estado
islámico y en proceso de acercamiento a
combatientes afiliados al qaeda
y otro elemento importante es el
creciente endurecimiento de la Esfera
política en la supresión
tanto en el contexto de los regímenes
militares que han llegado al poder
mediante golpes de estado en Mali
burkina
como en el endurecimiento de los
regímenes civiles
también importantes señalar que las
relaciones con la sociedad civil en
particular se están endureciendo de
forma muy
en toda esta subregión de África
occidental
finalmente el último elemento es por
supuesto esta revancha de la geopolítica
en la que vemos un actor como Rusia
ganar cada vez más peso
Pero en qué otros actores como Turquía
por ejemplo también están cada vez más
presentes por no mencionar el hecho de
que dentro del campo europeo occidental
también están surgiendo competiciones en
realidad los aliados tradicionales de
Francia pretenden aprovecharse de las
dificultades que atraviesa el país
y podemos considerar que la salida de
los militares franceses y la elección de
Mali y burkina faso de recurrir a Rusia
como nuevo socio es una victoria para
Moscú en la región
[Música]
yo no lo vería así Creo que es mejor
darse cuenta de que hoy en día los
estados africanos se encuentran en una
lógica de expansión y ampliación de sus
asociaciones tradicionales
Más allá de las oposiciones que puedan
estar en el origen de enemistades o
incluso de enfrentamientos entre sus
diferentes socios
si tomamos un estado como níger hoy es
el principal Aliado estratégico y
militar de Francia en la región del
sahell pero Rusia y Turquía también son
socios importantes de este país
Así que creo que hoy los estados
africanos pero también sus opiniones
públicas se encuentran en una posición
en la que sienten que tienen que hacer
valer sus propios intereses sus propias
visiones de futuro Más allá de los
planteamientos promovidos por cada uno
de los propios socios
En mi opinión África es cada vez más
protagonista de su propio futuro
en los últimos años hemos visto los
límites de la solución militar en la
lucha contra el terrorismo en el zagel
que cree que podría ser eficaz para
erradicar el yihadismo en la zona
en primer lugar es sumamente importante
darse cuenta de que estos grupos
extremistas radicales y armados no son
homogéneos al contrario chocan entre sí
de forma muy intensa
por un lado están los grupos yihadistas
afiliados al qaeda que luchan
violentamente contra los grupos
afiliados al estado islámico
y esta oposición es absolutamente
importante para entender No solo la
dinámica de la guerra sino también la
dinámica de la paz
de hecho Parece que la opción del
diálogo político y por tanto de la
negociación con algunos de estos grupos
armados está siendo considerada por
muchos actores incluidos las propias
autoridades
se ha promovido durante varios años la
opción de negociar con grupos afiliados
al qaeda e incluso níger está negociando
con ciertos elementos del estado
islámico
hoy Es evidente que estos grupos
yihadistas han avanzado tanto y sobre
todo se han arraigado tanto al nivel
local
que será muy difícil no encontrar puntos
de negociación con ellos y escuchar un
cierto número de sus reivindicaciones
relativas a la forma del Estado la icono
y al sistema educativo laico o no y
también con respecto a la administración
de la justicia
Muchas gracias por estar con nosotros en
África siete días
vamos ahora a Sudáfrica donde el
presidente City la rama fosa ha
declarado el estado de catástrofe
nacional en un intento de frenar la
profunda crisis eléctrica que está
minando la vida cotidiana y la economía
de la primera potencia Industrial del
continente
los 60 millones de sudafricanos llevaban
semanas esperando este momento en Ciudad
del Cabo precedido por la guardia
nacional el presidente de Sudáfrica
civil rama fosa se presentó ante los
parlamentarios para pronunciar un
discurso sobre el estado de la nación y
actualizar sobre la crisis energética
que asola el país desde hace meses
la agencia Nacional de gestión de los
desastres ha clasificado la crisis
energética y sus consecuencias como un
desastre por tal motivo declaramos el
estado de catástrofe nacional
pocos minutos antes del comienzo del
discurso del presidente una escena
surrealista
[Aplausos]
vestidos de rojo unos manifestantes
intentaron subir al escenario para
exigir la dimisión del jefe de estado
antes de ser expulsados en los últimos
meses el presidente y su partido El
Congreso Nacional africano han visto
crecer las protestas a medida que los
cortes de electricidad aumentaban en
número y en duración llegando en varias
ocasiones a las 12 horas diarias sin luz
las necesidades son colosales el
principal productor de Electricidad se
enfrenta a una deuda de 21.000 millones
de dólares con unas centrales eléctricas
de Carbón anticuadas y deficientes
la ciudad de marrakes en Marruecos
acogió del 9 al 12 de febrero la primera
edición de su festival del libro
africano con charlas cafés literarios
exposiciones y lecturas de poesía el
evento fue celebrado bajo el lema África
con todas las letras sus organizadores
quisieron acercar al público y
escritores y crear un espacio para la
literatura africana en un continente
llamado según ellos a reinventar su
vínculo con el mundo nuestra
corresponsal en marraker Sofía catalá
estuvo allí y se reunió con
organizadores y escritores
de colonizar la cultura los cuerpos y
las identidades africanas para luchar
contra el racismo y contra las fronteras
impuestas todo poniendo en el centro en
la defensa de la tierra y de los
Derechos Humanos el festival del libro
africano de marrakech se celebra su
primera edición para ensamblar
literaturas y saberes ancestrales el
de la africanidad
estamos muy orgullosos de organizar esta
primera edición del Festival del libro
africano de marrakech que es un espacio
para el diálogo y reflexión que nos
acerca a un futuro que queremos trazar
desde una perspectiva africana
es esta novela trata de conectar
reflexiones sobre el origen de la
violencia y de esta manera une la
emergencia medioambiental y la
emergencia de la cuestión femenina en la
tierra
para explicar a la condición de las
personas que son sujeto de la migración
que a menudo es presentada de forma
miserable peligrosa sospechosa personas
que son parte de esa categoría que hemos
homogenizado todo el mundo habla de
migrantes clandestinos Aventureros pero
olvidamos las historias que hay detrás
las individualidades raíces y
trayectorias personales sexuales
la formación de colonizar la cultura se
trata hoy en día a mi modo de ver a
nivel de formación hacer que nuestra
cultura sea enseñada en las escuelas yo
creo que así con el tiempo los niños
tomarán conciencia de las formas
culturales africanas y podrán
transmitirlas y también mostrarlas
[Aplausos]
así cerramos esta edición de África
siete días Gracias por acompañarnos la
actualidad internacional sigue en France
[Música]